Speaker 1: Tomorrow's arrest, surrender and
arraignment of Donald Trump.
Is of paramount public interest.
This is a former president of the United States,
now indicted for crimes related to his candidacy
in 2016.
He is being prosecuted by the taxpayer funded
legal system and is the epitome of a public
figure, never mind just nationally, but globally.
The arraignment should be televised.
But will it be?
We do not yet know.
It is imperative that there be cameras in
the courtroom tomorrow, not only for the reasons
I just said, but also because, of course,
Trump is going to lie about what happens in
this proceeding.
He will say the judge was so unfair and the
prosecutors and everybody is just biased.
And one of the only defenses we have against
those lies is to actually have cameras showing
what is going on.
The New York Times Maggie Haberman appeared
on CNN and made the exact same argument.
Let's take a.
Speaker 2: Listen.
I mean, what do you think?
I mean, if there is a camera in the room,
that's a remarkable moment in and of itself.
But it could be important to actually get
a clear view of what happened in that that
courtroom.
Absolutely.
And there is a compelling public interest
argument to make.
It is absolutely true that New York New York
is really regressive in terms of cameras in
the courtroom.
I do expect there'll be an argument made.
I'm not sure what the ruling will be on that.
But it's interesting, I was thinking as you
were asking that question and one of the things
we saw over and over, both with Michael Cohen
in terms of Trump and then other people in
the White House, people have a habit of taping
Donald Trump and they have a habit of taping
Donald Trump because he spends his own reality
and will contradict whatever people say about
him.
A camera would be pretty vital in terms of
people understanding what happened and not
being told that something that's fake news.
And in an era where Trump is saying that all
of these reports are not true.
I think there is a compelling argument for
it.
I am skeptical that it will happen.
Just I covered courts in this state.
I know how against cameras in the courtroom
judges are here.
But I do think there is going to be a compelling
argument.
Speaker 1: And.
Speaker 3: Even toggling to the actual trial
itself.
Imagine what the public interest in that will
be.
And so will there be cameras allowed to depict
what occurs on the day to day?
Because I think certainly people would want
to know right now.
Speaker 1: I don't know whether there will
be cameras in the courtroom tomorrow.
I sympathize with the skepticism from Maggie
Haberman, because indeed, oftentimes there's
questions, why weren't there cameras in the
courtroom?
And sometimes it has to do with, well, it's
a federal court rather than a state court,
and there are different procedures there.
New York State also notoriously strict about
having cameras in the courtroom.
I can't think of any legal issue, any legal
proceeding where cameras in the courtroom
are more justified than the indictment of
a former president of the United States.
So by tomorrow, we will probably know more
to livestreams tomorrow, the arraignment in
the afternoon and the press conference at
Mar a Lago, if it's not canceled based on
a potentially forthcoming gag order.
It is going to be a crazy 24, 36 hours.
I'm glad to have you with us.
Remember that the David Pakman show is an
audience supported program.
Thank you to the stunning number of new members
over the last week as we have dealt with an
angry right wing mob coming after me.
But they haven't succeeded in.
Part of the reason is thanks to you and the
folks who have signed up at join Pacman dot
com.
Keep it going my friends.
You can use the coupon code indicted to save
on a membership at join Pacman dot com.
We all know who and what we're talking about
when we type that code in indicted use it
at join Pacman dot com you'll get the daily
bonus show and so much more